[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY: So welcome everyone.
Thanks for joining us today
for this very exciting Talks
at Google with Kevin Kwan.
So-- woo, yeah.
My name is Jeremy, and I
lead the Asian Google network
here at our Los Angeles office.
We promote the professional
development and community
involvement of our Googlers
and also bring you great events
like this.
So if you'd like to continue
seeing these events,
please reach out
to me afterwards.
We're always looking
for volunteers
to help out with this.
Just to tell you a
little bit about Kevin.
Born in Singapore, Kevin Kwan
moved to the United States
when he was 11.
After graduating with degrees
from the University of Houston
and Parsons School of
Design, Kevin worked for Andy
Warhol's "Interview Magazine,"
"Martha Stewart Living,"
and M& magaz--
company, the legendary
graphic design firm
headed by Tibor Kalman.
In 1999, Kevin establish his
own creative consulting firm
where he became a highly
sought after producer
of visual projects for
clients such as the New York
Times, the Museum of Modern
Art, TED.com, and Oprah Winfrey.
In 2013, Doubleday published
Kevin's first novel,
"Crazy Rich Asians,"
which became
an international
bestseller and has been
translated into 13 languages.
Its sequel, "China
Rich Girlfriend,"
also rose to the top of the best
seller list around the world
in 2015.
And last week, the final
book in the trilogy,
"Rich People Problems,"
debuted on the New York Times
best seller list at number 12.
Earlier this year,
Warner Brothers
announced they had greenlit
"Crazy Rich Asians"
and the movie is
now in production.
Last month SCX
entertainment announce
that it had acquired rights
to a new scripted drama series
to be written by Kevin.
Now please join me in
welcoming Kevin Kwan.
KEVIN KWAN: See if this Coke
will slide off or be nice.
Thanks so much for
being here today.
I really appreciate
your taking the time out
during your lunch to come
hear me say a few things.
It's really a treat to
be here at Google Venice.
Two years ago I had the honor of
speaking at Google headquarters
in Mountain View and my mother
happened to be in the Bay Area
at the time visiting a friend.
So I thought, why don't
I invite her along
to come check out Google?
Right?
My mom was at the
time, 76 years old.
And she had just been recently
been given her first iPad ever.
And her favorite thing
to do was go onto Google
and look up all the extremely
rare and deadly types of cancer
she thought she would get.
So she was excited
to come to Google.
And before I gave
my talk at Google,
we were given a
tour of Google HQ.
Lots of different departments
and divisions and really cool
stuff that she
couldn't understand.
And my mom is usually a very
talkative, social person,
but she was pretty quiet
through the whole tour.
And I just thought she
was bored out of her mind.
Then we were taken to
the cafeteria for lunch--
like the main
cafeteria, you know,
where apparently
Larry and Sergey
have a open house every Friday.
And my mom's face lit up.
I could see she was
impressed by the food,
the amazing selections.
And then when she found
out that food was free
her eyes went huge.
And you know, I think she went
to the Indian food station
a couple of times and shoved
some naan into her handbag
maybe.
So after lunch I gave my talk.
And then there was
a book signing.
And as I sat at the
desk signing books
for this long line of
people, I could see my mom
going up and down the
line talking to people.
And I was thinking,
what on earth
could she possibly be doing?
This is dangerous.
You know what I mean?
Like, is she trying to get some
secret Google code or something
like that?
Or find out more about cancer?
And then as the line
shortened, I could hear her.
And she was saying, to
everyone, excuse me,
could you find my
son a job here?
Are you guys hiring?
Is there something he can do?
My son is unemployed.
He needs a job.
So after we left
Google finally, she
said to me in the car, ai-yah,
I wish you could get a job here.
You'd be set.
You'd have health insurance.
You could use the
gym-- the amazing gym.
You can swim.
They have amazing curry.
And I will finally,
finally be proud of you.
So I think you guys--
some of you here can relate.
So some of you might know that
my first novel, "Crazy Rich
Asians," is being made into
a movie by Warner Brothers.
There's been a great deal
of talk and excitement
because this is the first
romantic comedy ever
in Hollywood history to
have an Asian male lead,
an Asian heroine, and--
thank you.
It's also the first Hollywood
produced studio movie
in 26 years to feature
an all Asian cast.
And actually only
the second movie
to do that in all of
Hollywood's history.
So it's pretty incredible
what's happening.
You know, the movie is being
produced by Nina Jacobson, who
did the Hunger Games movies
which made eight gazillion
dollars I think.
And John Chu is
directing and he's
the amazing director of
movies like the Step Up movies
and, you know, after
"Crazy Rich Asians"
he's going to do Lin-Manuel
Miranda's "In the Heights."
he's the super hot director that
brings such an amazing vision
to the film.
So naturally from the moment
the film was announced,
there was so much excitement
about who is going to be cast.
We found our two
leading ladies early on.
Constance Woo was the
star fresh off the boat,
and is going to play
the American born
Chinese heroine, Rachel Chu.
And Michelle Yeoh, the legendary
Bond girl who everyone also
knows as, you know, from
"Crouching Tiger, Hidden
Dragon," she is going
to be Eleanor Young who
is the dragon mother-in-law
from hell that
wants to make Rachel's
life miserable, basically.
So finding all the
actresses-- because it
was a huge cast and all these
beautiful actresses playing
roles like Astrid, and
Araminta, and Peik Lin.
That was easy.
There were so many amazing
actresses from all across Asia,
from the US, from
England, and we sort of
have a dream team assembled.
Gemma Chan, the star of Humans.
Awkwafina, who's going to be
in the new "Ocean's Eight."
Sonoya Mizuno, who really
stole the show in "Ex Machina"
and "La-la Land."
So that was amazing.
But when it came
to casting the men,
especially finding our
leading man, Nicholas Young,
we had an unbelievably
challenging time.
There were some wonderful
character actors
of Asian descent.
But we suddenly realized that
there are very few actors
between the ages of
25 and 35 out there
who can really fulfill that
romantic leading man role.
You know, who can be the
next Asian Ryan Gosling.
And finding one who could
do a flawless British accent
was even tougher.
So it surprised all
of us that there
was such a small
pool of people that
were available and could do it.
But it really shouldn't
have surprised us.
John Chu and I really quickly
realized that it's really
a matter of culture.
The both of us
grew up in families
that immigrated from Asia,
so we knew the issues well.
The simple fact is
that Asian men--
not just in the US,
but around the world--
are raised from a
really early age
to focus on excelling in
the professional realm.
So to go to the best
schools and work at the most
prestigious companies.
So if you're a good looking,
smart, ambitious young Asian
guy between 25 and
35, you're most
likely going to be
a doctor, a lawyer,
or working at Goldman Sachs,
or working here at Google,
don't you think?
I mean, I can see
probably some of you
out here that could
have auditioned.
And why didn't you, right?
So that was very
interesting to discover.
And there is little to no
support for Asian boys growing
up to ever become actors,
writists, dancers, you know--
all of that.
And in fact, I think
telling your Asian parents
you want to go into
acting is probably
worse than telling them that
you got your teacher pregnant--
your gym teacher, you know.
So this goes back to
my mom and her quest
for me to work at
someplace like Google.
Yes, there's a part of her
that's so proud of me that
I've written a book that's--
she sees on book
shelves at Barnes Noble.
Or like gets angry at them when
they don't have it in stock.
But I truly believe she would
be even happier if I called her
up and told her tomorrow, hey,
I'm going to go to law school.
That's just the
plain fact of it.
So for me, leading a creative
life for the past two decades--
going to journalism school,
going to art school,
making experimental films
for weird dance companies
in New York.
All that has been a
complete act of rebellion.
Quiet rebellion, but a
rebellion nonetheless.
And when we found our leading
man for "Crazy Rich Asians,"
Henry Golding, who is half
Malaysian and half British
and who has grown up in Malaysia
and now lives in Singapore,
I realized we had
so much in common
because he was also a
rebel in his own way.
He never went to university.
He dropped out of
school at age 15
and went and apprenticed
at a hair salon.
That was the fun, cool,
creative thing to do.
And he actually became a
leading hairdresser in London,
and just last week cut my
hair on the beach in Malaysia.
So it's really surreal to get
your hair cut by the leading
man that you've
created in a book,
and now he's cutting your hair.
But it was a great haircut.
Anyway, at age 23,
he left London and he
was so unbelievably
handsome, everyone
kept saying you should be an
actor, you should an actor.
So he moved to Asia
to pursue that.
And the rest is history.
And then as I began
meeting all the other cast
members, all of the actors--
Ronnie Chang, who is so
amazing in the Daily Show,
Remi Hii who is from Marco Polo,
Chris Pang, just to name a few.
I realize we all
shared similar stories
of this sort of quiet rebellion
in one way or another.
So I just got back,
as I said, from being
on the set of "Crazy
Rich Asians" in Malaysia
and at first I wasn't
planning to go.
I mean, there was so much
happening with my book being
launched, everything like that.
And I didn't want my presence
to really distract the cast
and distract John.
But one by one, the actors
started contacting me.
And I would get
texts from Henry,
like why aren't you here?
Like, you have to be here
to see the production.
And Chris Pang, who is the star
of Netflix series Marco Polo,
he said, get your ass on a plane
right now and come to Malaysia.
Something very special is
happening here right now.
So I did.
I went to KL two weeks
ago, and arriving
on the set of the film--
which was this historic
mansion they found on top of KL
that they are using to
be Tyersall Park, which
is the mansion for my books--
it was one of the most surreal
experiences of my life.
You know, to sort
of see the sets,
see these settings
I only wrote about,
and to meet these characters
that were only in my mind,
be real and living people.
It was really amazing
and kind of surreal.
But the most wonderful thing I
don't think I'll ever forgot,
was just kind of the
excitement and the look
of exhilaration in the
eyes of all these actors.
And I realized-- I mean, I
realized that for most of these
actors that's assembled here,
the ones especially that
didn't grow up in Asia, this was
a life changing moment for them
because for the first time,
these actors and actresses from
the US, from Canada,
from Australia,
from all around the world--
they were getting
to play roles that
weren't based on stereotypes.
They weren't playing supporting
roles in white men's movies.
They weren't Asian mafia
gangsters, or Vietnamese call
girls, or that
computer geek that
can hack through the
firewall in three seconds.
Even if they had
the smallest parts,
they all felt like they were
being treated like leading men
or women.
They each had trailers.
That had dedicated assistants
and makeup artists.
And they, for the first time
ever, they all felt like stars.
Interestingly enough, I
also met some of the actors
in the film that
came from Asia--
you know, the ones from
Singapore, Malaysia, Hong
Kong, China.
And for them, they were
excited to be in the film,
but it wasn't that
big a deal for them.
This was another movie.
A great movie and part
of, but another movie.
And one night after
the shoot at wrap,
a whole group of actors
from all around the world,
we sat around having drinks.
And all the actors began
to share their experiences
of growing up where they were,
whether it was Melbourne,
Australia or in the middle
of the country in the US,
and how they had
all come to acting.
One Asian-American actor
talked about how incredible
it was for him to
be in this film
because for once he wasn't the
token Asian guy, and the only
Asian guy in the whole
cast of white people.
And he could finally
play a role where he
was an attractive, desired man.
And that was huge for him.
And it was amazing just to
watch the reaction of the Asians
based in Asia, You the actors.
Because for them,
it was a revelation.
These people-- actors like
Pierre Png of Singapore--
he's the Brad Pitt
of Singapore--
or Carmen Soo, who is like the
Jennifer Aniston of Malaysia--
you know, Malaysia's Darling--
they've only acted in
films with other Asians.
And they're huge stars
in their own country.
So for them, they really had
no concept of the challenges
Asians in other
countries face trying
to break into the creative arts.
And a few of them didn't even
know about the whole Hollywood
whitewashing controversy at all.
So they were absolutely
floored to discover all this
and to learn that the movie
has become kind of symbolic
of a whole other movement.
So I have to confess, I was like
one of those Singapore actors
not too long ago myself.
When I wrote my first
novel, I was simply
trying to write a funny book
that my friends could enjoy.
I never imagined it would ever
be published, first of all.
We have my amazing
agent in the audience,
Alexandra Machinist
to thank for that.
I never imagined it would
make any sort of impact.
And it didn't really
even hit me until I
was touring for the
first book in Toronto
and I met a journalist
who was interviewing me,
and he told me that he
had first found the book
and was very skeptical of it.
"Crazy Rich Asians,"
what is this?
Is this going to be another
book that offends Asians?
But he decided to read it.
And he told me he read the book
cover to cover in one night
and when he was finished,
he started crying.
And he said, I didn't cry
because of your story.
I cried because, for the
first time in my life,
I felt that I had read a
book where I could truly
identify with the characters.
I was reading about a guy
that seemed kind of like me,
who's empowered, who's creative,
who's confident and smart,
and who doesn't live his
whole life being wrapped up
in the issue of being Asian.
So I found a really
interesting quote
from the playwright,
David Henry Hwang.
And he was talking about
why the top movie stars
who are of Asian descent who
make it big in Hollywood,
they're all native born Asians--
you know, Jet Li, Jackie
Chan, Chow Yun Fat.
And he says, why is it that
the most bankable Asians that
have emerged from this tend
to be foreign born Asians
as opposed to
American born Asians?
I think Asians who
grew up in Asia
aren't wrestling with
identity questions
as Asians who grew
up in America.
Since they grew up
not in the minority,
they had a sense of themselves
that wasn't compromised.
And that observation for me
was sort of an aha moment.
I mean, I moved from
Singapore when I was 11
and I had grown up
in a world where
I was part of the ruling class.
So I never realized
how much help that was,
having that beginning
in Asia that helped me
when I moved to the US.
And I think, really, I
would have never dared
write a book called "Crazy Rich
Asians" if I'd grown up here.
So I really hope that as
more movies, TV shows, books,
creative content,
whatever, gets dispersed
into the world featuring
diverse international casts--
not just Asians,
but of all races--
acting alongside Western actors
on an equal playing field,
new generations
of kids will feel
empowered to make creative
choices with their lives.
You know, to rebel, to
become artists, or writers,
or dancers, or go to
film school, or art
school, or acting
school, and to be
able to make their moms proud.
Even if, like me, they
can't get a job at Google.
Thank you.
JEREMY: Thanks again for
coming to join us today.
Thank you all in the room here.
And we all want to say hi
to our live stream, where
AGN is in 10 different offices
across the states here.
KEVIN KWAN: Oh, god.
JEREMY: No worries.
I'll get you the
numbers afterwards
for how many live stream
participants we had.
We also have an
online forum where
people submitted questions.
So we have 15 questions
here, 41 votes.
So I'm going to ask is
in order of popularity.
But definitely we
want to open it up
to the audience for any
questions that you all have.
We have this very exciting cash
box in the back of the room.
We'll start throwing
that around.
Don't be afraid of it.
It's foamy.
It's soft.
It's like a pillow.
So embrace it.
Don't avoid it.
So Sage will start tossing
that around in a little bit.
But to kick us off, I'll go
ahead and ask a question here.
This is from Kelly Bailey
in our New York office.
Hi, Kelly.
KEVIN KWAN: New York!
JEREMY: What do you
attribute your book's
widespread popularity
amongst American audiences,
both Asian and non Asian?
Were there any conscious
things you considered
to appeal to a wider
audience while writing,
or was this just a
happy coincidence?
P.S., love your
books, smiley face.
I hope I captured that.
KEVIN KWAN: I really didn't have
any specific audience in mind
when I first wrote
"Crazy Rich Asians."
It was really-- I was writing it
for my friends because I would
always--
I would come back from Asia
with all these crazy stories
about people like that, and they
would be like, write it down.
Write it down, make it a book.
And so I really began it as
a collection of short stories
that I would circulate
to friends of mine
in New York who
instantly happened
to be a lot of Europeans and--
a lot more white people
than Asians, I have to say.
So it never was meant for
an Asian audience, per se.
And I just think that what
I found, going to book clubs
and really meeting fans
from all over the US
who tend to
predominantly be white--
you know, I think that's really
80% of my core audience--
everyone just wants
fresh new stories.
Everyone wants to be transported
to a new place, a new world
to discover something new,
and to get lost in a story.
And this connected.
This was a new story.
It wasn't just the same
old boy meets girl--
not to condemn or in
any way through a shade
at Nicholas Sparks,
because everyone--
all his characters are beautiful
blonde people that live
in North Carolina by the beach.
People were ready
for something new.
And that's what they wanted.
And I think
Asian-Americans actually
were the second wave that came.
Because at first I think
there was a lot of hesitance.
What is this book?
There was suspicion,
like, is this
going to portray
us in a bad way?
But as the word got out, I think
I was embraced by that audience
too.
So I'm really thankful for that.
And in Asia, it was
a hit from day one.
They were ready for it
because they see this world
every single day.
They see the obnoxious
20-year-old couples
in Rolls Royces, things like
that, and they were like, wow,
this is fun.
We get this immediately.
So it's had this lovely
sort of ripple effect.
JEREMY: Awesome.
Cool.
Anyone in the audience?
Should we throw the
foam ball around?
Who's our brave first
question in the audience?
Yay.
All right, up front.
AUDIENCE: Ready to
catch the cash box?
KEVIN KWAN: Catch the cash box.
You can't ask a question
till you catch the box.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I've--
huge fan.
I've already read the book.
Id love to ask you--
KEVIN KWAN: The new one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Of course, preordered it.
I'd love to ask your
questions on that,
but I realize that might
spoil it for everyone.
So one question I have is,
it's definitely clear that--
or maybe I'm assuming-- but in
the "Crazy Rich Asians" book,
it seems like a
lot of the stories
are inspired from
real experiences.
And then when you
talk about your mom,
we were both joking that
sounds a lot like Mrs. Bing.
So I'm curious to know, like,
obviously this is fiction.
But can you elude more
on the aspects that
might be more closer to
reality, or things that you
might see more directly?
KEVIN KWAN: Almost everything
in my books I've seen
or in some way
experienced in my life.
Like, I can't-- I have
no imagination, really.
I'm just-- serious, I'm a
social observer, basically.
And I've seen these things
and I'm changing enough
to disguise people and not
get sued, or get killed--
you know what I mean.
But, yeah, I couldn't
make this stuff up.
Plastic surgery for a fish?
I could not make that stuff up.
So a lot of it-- and the
characters, a lot of them
are inspired by real people.
So they're amalgams of
different real people.
AUDIENCE: Who are
you in the book?
KEVIN KWAN: I'm not in the book.
I'm just the boring guy
that's at the parties,
being very awkward, watching
all these fabulous people
do their thing.
AUDIENCE: So you've known
someone who has been--
received a ton of food, a
ton of wine, and then in,
"China Rich Girlfriend," Rachel
gets like basically ransacked
into doing a procedure to
try and see if she's pregnant
or she's ovulating.
Did that happen in your life?
KEVIN KWAN: Oh, yeah.
That really happened.
Someone I know got
ambushed into having
to submit to very
invasive medical tests,
because the family
wanted to know, like,
is this a viable
woman for our family?
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
KEVIN KWAN: I mean,
it's outrageous.
It's kind of
offensive, actually.
But I turned it into
a joke in the movie.
Yeah.
Funny.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is, like, so much
of the first book, even
the whole series, talks
about these families want to be
secret and hiding their wealth,
right?
So how do you think the Asians
are in Singapore and Malaysia,
react to the rich
kids of Instagram,
like Dorothy Wang who is
flaunting her wealth--
like Asian wealth in public?
Like, do you feel
like that-- which is
such a contrast to your book.
KEVIN KWAN: I think there
are so many different types
of wealthy people in Asia now.
And there are the sort of
Dorothy Wang equivalents, who
are loving this and love it.
And they interact as much
on social media themselves.
But then there's also
another, you know--
the older money tends to
really kind of look down
on the new money.
And so, of course, for
them, they're like OK,
you want to go do this?
OK, get kidnapped.
That's fine.
Fine by me.
A lot of the secret--
secrecy is really protective
because, you know,
these families
have known the repercussions
of wealth for generations.
So it's not being
secret for the sake
of being secretive,
it's secretive because--
in their past, like,
shit has happened.
Family members have been
kidnapped or extorted
and all these
things have happened
to really force
families to really
be much more kind of private.
AUDIENCE: We can keep going.
JEREMY: How about we
toss it back to our folks
over in New York City?
Gloria asks our
next question here.
What inspired you
to become a writer?
And what challenges did
you face on your journey?
And how did you overcome them?
KEVIN KWAN: Oh, wow,
how long does she have?
JEREMY: She got four votes,
so it's pretty high up there.
KEVIN KWAN: OK, cool.
You know, I always--
from high school
and on to college,
I studied creative writing.
I always wanted to be a writer.
I felt that that
was the first time
I could really express
myself creatively
in any meaningful way.
So I went to school.
I got my first degree in
journalism and creative writing
and I graduated.
And I couldn't make
a living, basically.
So I did what
everyone else does.
I went back to school.
I went to art school, where it's
even harder to make a living.
But, you know, I had this
idea that I'm a great writer.
I'm a great communicator.
And if I can learn all
these amazing multimedia
skills like web design and video
design and interactive design,
and I can bridge those two, I'll
be like this bad ass content
creator on all ends.
And that never
happened, of course.
So I spent 15 years sort of--
I fell into the consulting world
where I worked for companies
like TED.com.
I helped to launch
their website reboot.
And I would produce these
massive coffee table
books for Oprah Winfrey, and for
famous architects, and actors,
and stuff like that.
So I just kind of
fell into a world
where I could make money,
literally, and support myself
in New York, which
was not cheap.
And then in 2010, my dad died.
And that was a big wake
up call, because I always
knew I wanted to write
a book, sort of inspired
by my childhood.
And I always thought, I'll
wait till I'm retired.
I'll do it when I'm 65.
And losing my dad,
and also talking
with him about my childhood
and we spent a lot of time
together in his final
months, it kind of
refreshed all that for me.
And I said, you know what?
This is the time to do it.
Like, I'm not going
to wait till I'm 65.
I might not live till I'm 65.
So I'm going to do it now and
just make it fun, and just
write it for my friends--
or for myself, just to
remember these stories.
And that's kind
of what happened.
And then Alexandra
got my manuscript.
I think you were told
to throw it away, right?
Or to reject it.
She was told to reject it.
And she didn't reject it.
And here we are now.
Yeah.
JEREMY: Magic happened.
KEVIN KWAN: Magic happened.
JEREMY: All right, who
has got the cash box?
KEVIN KWAN: You need to
throw it back over there.
Right behind you.
AUDIENCE: I kind
of, like you, also
always wanted to write
a book, but ended up
studying computer science.
I actually grew up
in Singapore and--
KEVIN KWAN: I can tell.
AUDIENCE: --came to
the US for college.
But I also took creative
writing classes in college.
And what they taught to us
was to write what you know.
But what I knew always seemed
so foreign from what everybody
else in class was writing.
And I was like, there's
no way anybody's going
to be able to relate to this.
And--
KEVIN KWAN: That's exactly
what I thought, too.
That's why I thought
it was unpublishable.
But I sort of went for it.
Sorry to interrupt
your question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
No, that's inspiring to me,
because when I read your book,
I was like, this is what I know.
And I'm-- maybe not particularly
that world, but it's Singapore.
And it's what I grew up
in, and I've always--
I was-- I've been
trying to write things
set in America,
because that's what
everybody seems to want to read
and to know how to read here.
But I think your
book has given me
that insight that maybe
it's possible for me
to write what I know.
So maybe it's more of a comment
than a question, so, thank you.
KEVIN KWAN: I think
it's very possible.
And I think
publishers out there--
not just publishers, but
people in film, people in TV--
they're looking for
fresh ideas that
aren't just the same stories set
in the same places, especially
now.
So I would encourage
you to just go for it.
AUDIENCE: Is this something you
knew before you started writing
or is this what you've
learned in your experience?
KEVIN KWAN: That's what I--
I mean, that's what
I've learned, really,
just in my experiences for
the last five, six years.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Well, thank you.
KEVIN KWAN: I think there's
a question back there,
the guy in the fedora.
JEREMY: Yeah, good catch.
AUDIENCE: Hello
KEVIN KWAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Very nervous, sorry, I rarely
talk in front of people.
But I just wanted to say
that it's really inspiring
and I'm really grateful to have
you here and experience you
coming to Google and
giving pretty much
your life story in short.
And I-- it's funny
enough, because my wife,
she's a Asian-American
writer-- or is aspiring--
and she's pushing out
a novel now, hopefully.
And she read your book--
I'm sorry, "Rich People
Problems," "Crazy Rich Asians."
And she said, about "Crazy
Rich Asians," the same thing,
that she cried because it
inspired her because she's,
as an Asian-American
and not a native Asian,
that she has to deal
with that problem.
And she struggles
with her image a lot.
And watching her go through that
process of writing and saying,
I can't do this, and she's
already like 300 pages in.
She's like, I don't
know what else to do,
or what else to write.
It's-- she struggles.
KEVIN KWAN: She's doing it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
KEVIN KWAN: I can tell
that she's really doing it.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
And I tell her this.
And I said look, Kevin did it.
And it's funny because, I
say look, he's doing it.
And that's all you have to say
to yourself that you can do it
as well.
And she said-- she told me to--
she texted me
saying, oh, my god,
you need to tell him,
and ask his agent,
that if she could read my
writing and all this stuff.
But I just wanted to say--
AUDIENCE: It's cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you Alexandra.
But I just wanted to say,
from the bottom my heart--
because it inspired me too.
Because I actually know John
M Chu as well, because I've
worked with the LXD, and he
has produced that film series,
because I'm a aspiring
dancer as well.
So, small world, but I just
want to say thank you very much.
KEVIN KWAN: Thank you.
And I just want to--
tell your wife, you
know, one page at a time.
And every day I had self-doubt.
And everyday I was thinking,
why the hell am I doing this?
But some thing made me just
keep going until I was done.
So good luck to her.
Thanks.
There's a question back there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Kevin.
KEVIN KWAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm so happy
to be here today.
I'm actually from
The New York office.
KEVIN KWAN: Yay.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, really
glad to be in town.
I had a question for you, and
maybe this is a little deeper
beyond the movie.
But I wanted to ask you how
you would address the identity
crisis between first and
second generation Asians today?
So I'm kind of a border first
generation, second generation
Asian.
I came here when I
was around 2 and 1/2
and grew up in a very rural
part of South Carolina.
And now I'm living in the city.
And I feel like a lot of
the issues in your book,
I can relate to, but at
the same time I can't--
I can relate to in a sense where
my removed family on WeChat
are posting about a
lot of these things
that they're going through.
But that I'm living
in a countryside,
right, growing up and playing
basketball or riding a scooter.
So how do you address people who
are in this interstitial place
then?
How do you bridge that gap?
KEVIN KWAN: I wish I
had the answer for you
because I'm trying to
figure it out myself.
And I think for me,
the creative process
has been really healing
and really enlightening.
As I wrote, I was beginning
to understand my family more,
and situations the
characters would go through
are a lot of situations
I go through.
The struggle between
family commitment
and your own
personal fulfillment,
that I think is one of the core
issues of the intergenerational
struggles within the
Asian communities--
not just in the US,
but in Asia, too.
I think that's a big thing
that's really happening.
And we're all
muddling through it.
And I think you see the
characters in my books,
too, might have a
billion dollars,
might be beautiful like
Astrid, but they're still
dealing with their
mothers and their fathers,
and the repercussions
of their actions.
So my formula was
to just be creative.
And to just really tried to
find voice to my expression,
and that for me has been really
healing and very enlightening.
So I hope you find yours
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Kevin.
Been meaning to read your books.
Haven't yet, but I will now
that I've-- you know, you came.
Anyway, I realize this is
probably beyond your expertise
but since you study
human nature and stuff
I thought I'd ask you anyway.
I have a one-year-old boy
and another girl on the way.
I was trying to figure out,
I'm to be raising them here
in California.
They're going to be
an ethnic minority.
I think Asians are 12% of
the state or something, still
pretty minorityish.
Do you feel like it's,
overall, more productive
for children to have their
ethnic identity emphasized
and be like, this is who you
are, your identity, blah, blah?
Or more deemphasized,
like, you know,
just play the cards you're
dealt. Don't worry about it.
Just do your best, et cetera?
KEVIN KWAN: Wow.
I don't feel I can really answer
that with any true expertise.
I think, first of all, it's
great that you're here in LA,
because I think we see so
much more diversity here
than almost anywhere
else in the nation.
You're not in South
Carolina in a rural town.
I grew up in a town
where I-- there
were really three other Asians.
But I didn't have the sort of
identity issues that they had.
I realize that now.
And I realize now
why they hated me
because I would interact
so freely with everyone,
whereas they really felt
siloed in this Asian world.
I think you have to find a
balance where you can raise
them to be proud of their
identity, and the history,
and the amazing legacy
of where they come from.
I don't know if you're
ethnic Chinese or Korean?
AUDIENCE: I am, but my
wife's Filipino, so--
ish.
KEVIN KWAN: I mean,
two amazing cultures.
So I think if you can balance
that with also integrating them
into this world, but
also showing them
how great their ancestry was.
If you can travel with them back
to Asia or to the Philippines--
I mean, I think Filipinos
are just so cool--
one of the coolest
cultures in the world.
I think that will really help
them bridge the two worlds.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
KEVIN KWAN: Thanks.
JEREMY: Oh, that was close.
Good throw, though.
AUDIENCE: So I ask this question
on Dory, but no one voted it,
so I'll just ask
anyway, on my own.
Yeah, I read all three books.
And I feel like they're
really well tied together.
So I'm just curious,
did you have
a kind of a vision for a
trilogy when you first started?
Or did you just write
and go along with it
and refer back to the
first book when trying
to tie everything together?
KEVIN KWAN: I
really had a vision.
I really wanted to write--
one, I knew the story
I wanted to tell.
And I knew would take like
1800 pages to tell it.
And I knew that that
would never get published.
And so, I thought trilogy
was the way to go with that.
And I'm lucky I actually
got to write three books
and really tell the full story.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JEREMY: Going off
of that question,
I just want to ask this
one from the online forum.
Lauren from New York
asks if you can tell us
about some crazy rich
Asian experiences
that you've had like
personally in your own life.
I know you said that you're
not in the books themselves,
but how about, like, anything
that maybe didn't make it
into the book, that didn't
make it into these three books?
KEVIN KWAN: There's so much.
Where to begin?
I'm totally stumped
at the moment
because, you know-- let's see.
I've been to crazy weddings,
for example, that were
even crazier than the books--
than what I describe
in the books.
So that's one of them.
Keep telling the stories.
Weddings involving three palaces
in Europe, in one wedding,
things like that.
And amazing ice
sculptures and little kids
getting their tongues stuck
licking the ice sculptures,
and, you know.
It's just a very interesting
and varied world.
And it's more about--
I remember characters,
more, and meeting
these strange,
interesting characters.
When I was in Shanghai
there was this person
that wanted to meet me
because he had read my books.
And so it was sort of
very covertly set up.
And he took me to
his private club.
And he's one of
the seven members
of this very private club
that only has seven members,
because it's so exclusive.
But it was this vast estate
in the middle of Shanghai--
this amazing huge mansion
with gardens and sculptures
and water features and
private chefs, just
to entertain seven
people and their guests.
So it's mind blowing,
what's happening out there
that I've been lucky.
Or unlucky to have witnessed.
JEREMY: Will go ahead and go
for another Dory question here
and then we'll wrap up
in just a little bit.
So if there are any last
questions in the audience,
definitely tee that up.
Grace in Mountain View asks,
career tracks in liberal arts
are generally not very
popular or strongly enforced
in the Asian culture.
What kinds of
obstacles and pressures
did you face as an Asian writer?
And what did you
learn in the process?
KEVIN KWAN: You know I
was really lucky because I
had parents that
were actually very
open to my doing crazy things.
As much as my mom wanted me
to be a lawyer or a doctor
or to work at Google,
she didn't mind
that I went off and did this
strange thing that she couldn't
even explain to people, like,
what is a creative consultant?
You know, I can't even
explain it most of the times.
But I think that the struggle
really was all internal.
It's a struggle of self-doubt.
And as soon as I
began to write it,
you begin to see inroads as to
how you can make this happen.
So for me, I very quickly
was able to find an agent who
wanted to rep the book.
So I didn't have a struggle
that I think a lot of authors
go through for years
and years and years.
I have friends who have been
writing their novels for seven
years, or have
submitted their novels
to like 30 agents or publishers
who don't have the same luck.
And I don't know
what the answer is.
It's a tough, tough business.
I think any creative endeavor
is a tough, tough business.
And you just have to want it bad
enough, and to be persistent,
I think.
Did I answer the question?
JEREMY: I think so.
Persistency is key.
That's where I got.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
JEREMY: All right.
Any last cash box questions?
KEVIN KWAN: I think
there's one more from--
AUDIENCE: So, so much--
did I turn it on?
Yeah.
So, so much of the
book is wonderful food,
amazing fashion,
beautiful watches, gowns!
Like, where did you
get all that from?
Is it from-- obviously
you said real people,
but did you consult
with fashion designers?
Like, I would love about
that whole process.
KEVIN KWAN: Not really.
I mean, it's like I said,
it's all direct observation,
number one.
But as I began to
create the characters,
you sort of begin to imagine
how they will dress, basically.
And in the first
book I was really
trying to satirize this
culture of materialism,
and money, and people
being label whores,
because whenever I went
to Asia I would see that.
I would have people always
ask me, what are you wearing?
Who made your shoes?
Let's look at your watch.
Like, they're so obsessed
with labels, and everything
that you are wearing,
because people really
identify with brands there.
And it really signifies, and
it's so important to them.
And so I wanted to kind
of make fun of that.
And I asked my editor, I
was like, what do you think?
And she was like, I love it, and
the fans are going to love it.
And she was right, because more
and more-- in the second book,
I put in less brands
because I thought,
I'm really getting
to the story and I
don't have to describe what
everything Ashford is wearing,
in every scene.
And then the notes came
back from my editor.
Please describe everything
she's wearing in every scene,
like, head to toe--
and the guys, too.
Like, the fans want to know.
The readers love this.
And so that's what I've done.
Yeah.
Interesting story for
you from the movie--
John Chu is so dedicated to
getting every detail right,
but there was a moment
in the script where
a character gives another
character a watch as a present.
And so he said to me,
like, would this person
get this watch,
this certain brand?
And I was like, absolutely not.
And he's like, so what would
he-- what would he get?
I was like, well, you
know, this character
would be given probably
an amazing collectible
vintage Rolex Paul Newman
Daytona Panda, you know.
And so we found one.
Like we sort of went,
connect the dots,
and an amazing very
generous crazy rich Asian
lent us his $500,000 Paul
Newman Panda Daytona.
And it was flown around
the world on set,
with bodyguards,
in a special box
for a scene that lasted
literally, I would say,
quarter of a second.
Yeah.
But that's how much we wanted
to get every detail right.
JEREMY: Is that the
watch you have on now?
KEVIN KWAN: No.
I wish.
But it's funny, the actors were
like, it was your watch, right?
I was like, no.
Not even close.
JEREMY: All right.
Well, I want to thank Kevin
Kwan for joining us today
here at Google.
And thank you.
Let's go ahead and give
him round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KWAN: Thanks so much for
spending your lunch time today.
Appreciate it.
JEREMY: All right.
We'll stick around a little bit.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
If anyone has books--
JEREMY: Some of you
have books, so--
KEVIN KWAN: --or anything
to sign, I'm here.
Cool.
[APPLAUSE]